well you've heard the view of the the
scientists the chief
medical officer the chief scientific
advisor uh they're absolutely convinced
that uh this is the right thing to do
get
uh kids pupils back into school on march
the 8th
and that's that's what we're going to do
and i want to thank
uh parents teachers who've done so much
not just during the
the pandemic to look after kids at home
uh but also
teaching them uh throughout the pandemic
trying to keep them uh keep them going
and they know just talking to teachers
here and into pupils here
how important it is uh to get back into
the the classroom and
and that's what we're gonna do they've
done a great job in
making sure that uh it's kobe is secure
you can uh see all the preparations that
uh responsible schools have made uh
across the country and and that's
fantastic to see
um i just asked about the road map last
night now
there are some who think it's too slow
but a lot of people have been incredibly
cautious for a long
period of time and they'll see that in
april you can't see anybody else inside
and then you get to may
and you can see other people inside and
you can go to
public uh buildings with a thousand
other people
that feels like quite a rapid jump are
you sure that jumps like that can be
done in just a matter of
five weeks some people will say that
we're going to be
going uh too far some people say we're
going too slow
i think that the balance is right i
think it's it's a cautious but a
reversible
approach which is i think what people
want to see and the reason for the
the gap as you know is that it gives us
time
to look at the impact of each of the
changes each of the
relaxations the opening up the opening
ups that we're doing so
getting kids back into school massively
important for
the country we need time to assess what
that does
to uh the disease to the the prevalence
of
of covid and then again when you look at
the april the 12th
uh openings you need to look at the uh
the impact of that what does
essential retail do the uh the opening
of outdoor hospitality and so on you're
adding all the time
uh to the budget of risk and you need
time
to observe the impact of that so we
think it's
a sensible approach it's a prudent
approach but also as i think
people can see it goes on uh
irreversibly and we open up
on june the 21st in a way that
i don't think people would really have
thought possible
had it not been for the rollout of the
vaccinations it's it's those
vaccinations that
massive program led by the nhs that has
made all the difference
you're sounding pretty confident about
that june 21st deadline at the moment
there are some worries from
chief medical officers in wales that
actually that's a bit rapid how
what percentage chance how much
confidence should people have about that
hitting that final deadline at the early
summer i'm hopeful
but obviously nothing can be guaranteed
and it all depends
on the way we continue to be prudent and
continue to follow
the guidance in each in each stage and
that's why it's so important to proceed
in the
cautious way that that we are i think
people do understand it they can see the
the logic of what we're
uh what we're trying to do um but
genuinely
because of the immense possibilities now
of the vaccination rollout because
science has given us
this way of creating a whole a shield
around
our population uh we can really look at
that
uh june 21st date with some
uh optimism i think that that's what how
i put it
i've got i'm very optimistic that we'll
be able to get there
um i just want to ask you about um
immunity certificates i mean i think
everyone's going to end up calling them
vaccine passports whatever the
government does
um you announced review yesterday into
that can you just say a little bit more
about who's doing it how long it'll take
and in particular is there anything off
the table as part of that review
this is an area where you know we're
looking at a novelty
for our country we haven't had stuff
like this before we've never
thought in terms of having something
that you have to show to go to
uh you know a pub or theater uh that
and and so there are deep and complex
issues
that we need to explore ethical issues
about
what the role is for government in uh
mandating or
people to uh to have such thing or
indeed banning
uh people from doing such a thing there
are complex issues we need to work out
we can't be discriminatory against
people who
for whatever reason uh can't have the
vaccine there might be reasons medical
reasons why people
can't have uh a vaccine or difficulties
that they
uh you know the people some people may
genuinely
refuse to have one now i think that's a
mistake i think everybody
should have a vaccine
but we need to thrash all this out and
we've got time
because what we're doing is rolling out
the vaccination program
and that will go on for the next couple
of months and
in the interval uh what i want to see is
a proper review into the
the issue and that's going to be led by
um by michael gove by the chancellor of
duchy
of lancaster who will be uh producing i
will be getting the best
scientific moral philosophical uh
ethical
uh viewpoints on on it and will work out
the way forward i know the fervent
libertarians i will object but other
people will think that there is a
case for it and um when i when you look
at the
uh international side of things
international travel
there's there's no question that that's
where a lot of people a lot of countries
will be going and there will be
insisting on
uh vaccine passports in the way that
people used to insist on evidence that
you've been inoculated against
yellow fever or whatever so it's going
to come on the international stage
whatever